[Musique]
bonjour à la réunion bonjour le monde
entier comment allez vous si zot lé bien
mal et mieux alors aujourd'hui on est où
on est au guillaume alors on ne va pas
monter chez monsieur jean-marie 1 on a
déjà fait une émission d'ailleurs salué
jean marie on est juste en bas dans les
bambous dray et on va voir alexandre
donc des variétés de bambous et beaucoup
des noirs des jaunes et v à des fins
bref y'a pas de pandas ya pas de pandas
c'est comme ça panda et des bonbons ou
un panda alors vous allez me suivre
indirectement comme ça on va voir un
petit peu un émises mais quoi aller
diana
[Musique]
une idée née renée bijoux alexandre
bonjour comment il est eh ben les bons
et les noms les belles mais bell alors
déjà merci nous accueillir d'où est ce
qu'on est et dis nous ce que tu fais
alors là vous êtes près de dieu à 1000
mètres d'altitude à la bande musée du
guillaume et je suis planteurs de bambou
donc producteurs de différentes variétés
de bambous du monde des bars à des
variétés tempéré des variétés tropicale
et puis depuis très peu de temps de la
rose ancienne d'accord ben 12 est pas
bon vous aurez exactement ben buzet je
me suis trompé j'ai dit bon vous aurais
je mets tout un gros zéro avec mon
agresseur
[Musique]
en dix mois la culture du bambou et
c'est pas original en tout cas la
réunion du mois les gens ils viennent te
voir pourquoi les gens et c'est du bon
pourquoi de la déco entre autres mais
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres choses
c'est dans un premier temps pour
aménager le jardin et s'isoler des des
voisins lorsque les parcelles deviennent
de plus en plus petit le vis-à-vis de
plus en plus près des fois le voisin il
n'a pas toujours là peut-être qu'on a
envie d'avoir donc j'invente rien j'ai
fait ce que faisait les anciens mais
avec des variétés plus petit et plus
facile d'entretien
il ya rien de plus rustique et de plus
efficace contre le vent l'a vu tenir le
sol
enfin bon ça a de la gueule
c'est joli c'est joli bien taillée moi
je veux y aura une belle aux côtés de la
casse est bien joli cahier ou pas taillé
ça peut être laissé sauvage
oui mais oui bien sûr et là tu vas nous
montrer dont ben là on va commencer par
la nurserie on y va la raison cette
variété la vie tél
on voit de décembre ont fait les
boutures et on les voit ici aligner les
boutures donc c'est du plan pour faire
de l'alignement donc de la clôture et
on les fait en décembre et on les
ressort l'année d'après en octobre
novembre
donc c'est des cycles de 10 à 12 mois on
va les mettre sur ce plateau là bas en
rampe otages ils vont passer six mois un
an en recul tueur pour eux arrivé à la
hauteur souhaitée pour la vente
souvent on entend les anciens même des
jeunes marc madiot le bambou il faut
faire attention parce que ça casse le
béton ça pousse le mur je suppose que ça
dépend des variétés non exactement
alors on est très bien renseignés sur
les bambous en europe qui sont des
bambous tempéré qui sont des bambous à
tige souterraine qu'on appelle rhizome
d'accord alors cela sont des
envahisseurs et ils ont une capacité de
progression à la réunion que j'ai jamais
vu nulle part dans le monde qui peut
aller de 5 à 7 mètres par an où on ne
fait pas ces variétés là donc il s'agit
d'un tiers du règne les deux autres
tiers du règne sont des bombes ou
tropicaux qui pousse en touffe
et ça c'est un bambou sub tropicales ou
tropicales et il va pousser en touche là
tout va gonfler mais n'ira pas colonisé
d'accord moi le but c'est que je sois
pas au bout du fusil décrire d'accord
pendant la pause sceptiques du voisin
même que ça passe dans des endroits qui
va souhaiter quoi
[Musique]
avant de donner belle allée de bambou
c'est magnifique c'est vraiment joli
la prairie dedans bout elle date de
monsieur de villèle père dalle en fait
il les a fait rentrer et non pas de
madagascar mais d'asie pour faire des
tiges pour sécher le tabac d'accord
qu'est ce que tu a planté qu'est ce qui
est fait est ce qu'il y avait je suppose
qu'ils avaient quand même pas mal de
variétés à l'avant à l'endroit où il est
le terrain il y avait trois variétés
d'accord une tempéré donc le
phyllostachys réac et qui on trouve
partout dans le monde
il y avait une subtropical le bambou
agglo ses sens mais je connais pas ça sa
variété qu'on trouvait partout dans les
hauts de l'île on se forme de clôture et
le bambou de ravine-blanche isabelle il
ya risque est un tropicale donc sur
cette altitude ce terrain il y avait du
temps perdu subtropicales et du tropical
et c'est là que je me suis dit c'est ici
et dans le parc tu as combien de
variétés y en a plus d'une centaine plus
d'une centaine donc il arrive il ya
trois variétés
maintenant il y en a plus d'une centaine
il ya du boulot les enfants
il ya beaucoup de boulot il ya beaucoup
de prospection il ya beaucoup de voyages
il ya beaucoup de cadeaux il ya beaucoup
de grain qu'on germées
[Musique]
alors dis-moi qui sont en train de faire
quoi je vois qu'ils ont donc coupé en
tasses et les trucs là ils sont bas il
coûte deux lauréats
et ça ça va être remonté et branché
calibrer les parties tordu vont être
enlevées à la main et premio séchoir et
on des fonds n'a même pas le temps de
les faire sécher les clients les vols
tout de suite ouais là on peut faire des
haies des toits salvet ça devait être
bien fait d'aller vers des cages
d'escaliers on peut faire des petites
cabanes oui des varangue même avec cette
variété de là parce que quand elle est
sèche et les très très résistante
nallet
alors dit moi un petit peu cette variété
c'est là qu'elle alors ça c'est un top
pour la construction dans d'euros
calamus street
asper celui-là asper parce qu'il pousse
comme une asperge c'est utilisé dans
toute toute l'indonésie l'asie et
beaucoup à bali d'accord avec ça qu'ils
construisent à bali moi j'ai vu un
restaurant se faire construire il était
rez-de-chaussée plus premier étage plus
comble à en une seule tige il était
monté en quinze jours moi j'avais des
échafaudages en bambou mais immense
immense c'est impressionnant on ne dit
pas assez c'est quand même hein c'est
quand même un roseau c'est un arbre
c'est une herbe géante c'est une espèce
de dinosaure ouah ça vient couper couper
couper ça repoussera toujours qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire d'autre parce que bon
on a parlé de 2-2-2 d'entourer de lacs
ou de d'ornement et cetera
mais il ya aussi les les choeurs de
bambou coup consomment et c'est la
pousse de bambou alors celui là est un
excellent comestibles là on voit des
pousses qui ne sont pas sortis au mois
de février mars
on va voir des gros turillon sortir sur
le côté et c'est pour cela qu'on mange
d'accord on sait l'az en salade en
achard avec du boeuf avec des crevettes
ont montré avec tous ces riches en sels
minéraux et en vitamines et en silicium
et puis tout ça c'est de la coupe
combien de faire sur ces variétés là
c'est pas pas toujours les plus droite
c'est pas les plus grosses les plus
grosses et les plus droites sont déjà
partis je suppose que c'est d'aider des
plans qui sont là depuis des centaines
d'années non non pas du tout c'est nous
qui les avons planté avant ils ont été
plantés en 98 il était haut comme le
genou pendant trois quatre ans les a
aidés parce qu'il ya de la vie de ma
rogne à des galas béria du bringel donc
ont dégagé le tour pour qu'ils perdent
vers le ciel et après c'est eux qui font
de l'ombre au reste mais ça vit encore
et ici c'est ce que j'appelle ma
chapelle parce que quand les pouces
comme c'est la fin de l'été la voûte se
referment et ça fait un effet cathédrale
oui c'est magnifique c'est majestueux
ces grands
[Musique]
meilleurs voeux des mariés quand et si
un problème qui accepterait alors on a
fait ça on a fait le tour je suppose
qu'on a fait légèrement le tour en
prenant des raccourcis en prenant des
raccourcis
bon moi j'ai voulu m'arrêter devant ces
variétés de bambous noir c'est un gros
bonhomme ans oui c'est un bon gamin
c'est un bon goût qui fait partie de la
nature
le fait qu'ils soient noirs il devient
bombe ou d'ornement oui d'accord et tu
me parlais aussi d'une variété qui
s'appelait le petit blond des eaux alors
ti-blanc des os et une obtention réunion
ça c'est le sait la nature qui nous l'a
donnée un jour mon frère me dit ah bien
voir bien voir y ait un bambou qui a
fait des feuilles blanches avec des
rayures blanches sur la tige jeudi
vincent on laisse mûrir et quand il sera
prêt on fait des boutures et maintenant
me le demande dans les collections parce
que c'est celui qui est le plus blanc
entre septembre et décembre
il commence par des feuilles blanches
ait un peu de vert et il va devenir
blanc pur et dans les bas il est
carrément d'un blanc on va dire un blanc
un blanc baptême un blanc communion du
colorant
d'où est venue cette passion pour le
bambou est
depuis quand tu es à la réunion et que
tu t'occupes de cette bamboo bamboo
c'est vous c'est quelque chose qui m'a
touché j'avais à peu près cinq ans et
j'étais dans un centre d'accueil air
france et dès le premier jour j'ai été
donnée parce que c'est comme ça que ça
se passe dans la société et j'avais
trouvé dans ce parc
une touffe devant bout ou quand j'étais
à l'intérieur je voyais tout le monde
mais personne ne me voyait c'était ma
planche et j'étais peinard j'étais
c'était un lieu et un endroit pas un
endroit est un moment de ma vie
heureux dans un moment très malheureux
et qu'est-ce que j'ai refait
inconsciemment j'ai refait ma planque
ici et dans les bambous moi je suis je
suis j'entends les oiseaux je sais s'il
ya du monde
je sais je sais je sais comment sa vie
parce que je vois là je le ressens
d'accord ben écoute tu sais quoi
ouais j'ai entendu le téléphone qui
sonne moi je vais te laisser parce que
le monsieur il est très demandé
il est très demandé c'est une
multinationale lie à gignac est revenu
dans son écoute je te remercie je me
lève
c'était un plaisir alexandre à la
prochaine à la prochaine il ya des
clients qui t'appelle assez sûrement des
clients me coûte vas-y oui je te laisse
à plus tard à plus tard à plus tard à
bail
[Musique]
et voilà toutes les bonnes choses ont
une fin
il paraît je vous quitte avec une grande
tristesse rhodia com
alors je vous dis tout simplement
aurevoir
souriez rigoler et y ait la paix dans
les coeurs comme dit la romance et oui
détail très important dans la vie très
important on n'est pas du tout sorti de
l'auberge
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge parce
que là tu entres dans l'auberge
tu as des forêts de bambous c'est
magnifique tu vois des fois il ya même
des ddd des canards à l'admettre
cardinal van zyl
[Musique]